[BLANK_AUDIO]
Okay, Marty,
NSUserDefaults is by far the easiest
way to persist data to your device.
>> How does it work?
>> It's actually it's like
a dictionary that every now and
then automagically saves its contents.
>> And it can save my algorithm?
>> Yes, it saves data into a plist,
this stands for property list.
And even though it can only take certain
types such as data, string, number,
date, array or dictionary,
that's not a problem.
We're sending your message a string.
>> So if we go back to the past and
implement and NSUserDefaults on the text
input section of my phone's messaging
app, then when my phone dies and
the app turns off, it will have
saved the album I wrote out?
>> Yes, though.
>> What?
>> It's nothing.
>> What is it, Doc?
>> NSUserDefaults reads and
writes all in one go.
So that's why we try to
keep the size below 1 MB.
If it's bigger,
it would be taxing for the device.
But that should only a problem
if the file is tremendous.
Your algorithm can't be that big.
>> I wish I could remember.
>> Nah, I think that's impossible.
Actually, I'm certain it is.
NSUserDefaults will suffice.
Come Marty, we have no time to waste.
To the DeLorean!